Madeline's with us in Kansas City hi
Madeline how are you hi Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up I'm just
calling I need some advice my husband he
is just he will not get rid of his
credit cards he thinks the 401k is so
important and I just calling for some
advice he thinks you know he's a
blue-collar worker and he needs his
credit card blue collar worker means you
have to be stupid what's that mean
you're basically saying that we don't
make enough money to look enough money
just to stay out of that
that's basically what are you saying oh
that's kind of hopeless yes that's sad
oh yeah this guy yeah I mean um he is 28
and I mean I've paid off about two
thousand dollars of debt in like three
weeks now and I'm just trying to get him
on board with me so is he this much of a
hard head in other areas of his life
correct yes well this probably has to do
with how he how he grew up Paul you know
a family probably sat around said well
you know the working man cooter hood the
little man could get ahead I grew up
around some people like that too and my
parents were the opposite of that
they're like you can do anything if you
just get out there and do it you know
but that's that kind of we used to call
that in the south we call that poor
mouthing never heard that phrase walking
around I have not had running your mouth
acting like you're going to be poor your
whole life
Oh like I'm stuck I'm just stuck in a
mud puddle okay good old it's kind of a
grown-up form of whining you know and if
his family did that then they've made
him believe that there is no hope and
that's what that's what this all refers
to that's why it's so sad it's a
hopelessness it's saying well that might
work that might work for those those
people with the white collar but let's
blue collar working me and we can't do
that you know that's how I heard it said
as I sound familiar
yes yeah that's a whole
listeners that's rooted in class envy
and instead of going hating eighty-eight
percent of America's millionaires are
first-generation rich nine out of ten of
them started with nothing I got talked
to a minute ago 2.4 million dollars the
reason he got that as he saved it up you
know so I don't know how to crack the
this particular nut other than to
recognize it for what it is and it is
hopelessness and that keeping me from
being quite as aggravated with it if I'm
you or me because I want him to believe
he can win right and that his family's
all in and that you do control your
destiny
do you guys attend a church in the area
I know we don't okay all right
the I'm tempted to give you a Financial
Peace University but that's dangerous
because I don't plan to go to that class
by yourself and I'm not sure you can get
hardhead to go with you I mean I'm sure
maybe there is an incentive I I don't
know I don't know Senate visits free if
I give it to you that's the only
incentive so you're a you to go to the
class that's the only Senate incentive
is you're going to get your act together
you're going to learn something and you
know you'll start to believe that you
can win again
and I might get him in the class I can
get I can get I can you know I can get
past hard head I do it all time it's
what I do
but I'm telling you how to do that how
many y'all been married we've actually
been married for about four months yes
together for about nine years but
married for four months and I'm just
trying to get rid of our debt early on
yeah you're just finding it's very hard
to do things like this by yourself yes
and you're also finding the number one
cause of marital stress is financial
disagreement right and so you know what
you could let me give you the class but
I'll tell you this please don't go
without him and here's why because I'm
going to teach you so well that you're
going to get madder and madder and
madder at
and I don't want to cause you more
problems right I don't want to cause a
split you follow me so I would want to
be mad at the money and again there you
go yeah I don't want to make you matter
at him and I will if you go to this
class and because that's not the goal
here the goal is not to split you up the
goal is to make you tighter and make you
win together so anyway I'll give it to
you but but what I would tell him is
this you can what you working however
you want to do that but honey you do
this as a favor to me that's one thing
to thing you could say you know I was
doing some reading and I learned that
the number one cause of marital problems
and even the number one cause of divorce
is disagreements over money and we have
a disagreement over money right now and
I don't want this to continue and I sure
don't want it to get worse
please as an investment an act of love
into our marriage and investment into
our marriage please just come with me I
got the class given to us for free
didn't cost us anything
all we got to do is go over there and
just do that kind of an angle if you can
get him the class I can get past this
but I'm not sure in this type of a
setting I can break through 28 years of
training by his parents or his
neighborhood or whatever with one
conversation with his wife of four
months so um but that's you know I can
defeat the different mythologies that
he's got floating around in his head but
I got to get a hold of him to do that
probably and I don't know how to tell
you to do it at reuters don't so let me
give you the clasp you hold on I'll have
Kelley pick up we'll get you guys signed
up and I sure hope you can get there as
quickly as you can I'd love to have you
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]